a thanksgiving celebration for the queen
but the monarch being celebrated wasn't
there buckingham palace excused the 96
year old from the service at saint
paul's cathedral the decision taken with
great reluctance it said because of
discomfort she'd felt on thursday it's a
move many can understand
it's important that she looks after her
health we want her well we wanted to
keep going bless her so she does need a
rest it was a big day yesterday so i'm
assuming she had a little bit too much
port at the concert i think
the queen isn't the only one needing a
break watch the guard at the back
duty can take its toll
otherwise the service was well attended
deputising for his mother and leading
the rest of the royals was prince
charles
there were prime ministers past
and present
but listen to the crowd's reaction to
boris johnson and his wife carrie
boos competed with the cheers
partygate and other scandals have taken
a heavy toll on the prime minister's
popularity
also dividing the crowd were harry and
megan this was their first official
appearance together since quitting as
working royals in 2020
well i'm sorry to say i'm not a fan of
harry and megan i think they're very
very very disrespectful for the queen i
love the queen and i think they should
have been supported towards her i do
have respect for megan i think that she
has done amazing things and perhaps is a
tiny bit misunderstood
but yeah
i'm probably in the minority
meanwhile buckingham palace is clearly
trying to pace things for queen
elizabeth she's also been ruled out of a
trip to the horse races on saturday
an increasingly frail elderly woman who
unsurprisingly is finding four days of
partying just a bit much worry challenge
out to zero